[Music]  last night's Town Hall debate as I said  filled with undecided voters and the  consensus is that President Obama's  strong performance really helped him  sway some of these voters who were still  on the fence let's take a look at the  tape we've gone through a tough four  years there's no doubt about but four  years ago I told the American people and  I told you I would cut taxes for  middle-class families and I did I told  you I cut taxes for small businesses and  I have I said that I'd end the war in  Iraq and I did and we have gone after Al  Qaeda's leadership like never before and  Osama bin Laden is dead  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  that's what our founding fathers had in  mind  well most surprising he went with  Christina  [Laughter]